Друзі на цьому Святому місці я хочу
скористатися цією можливістю для того
щоби
привітати всіх українців з величезним
святом святом дня захисника
Вітчизни якщо запитати що вдалося
зробити за пть років моєї президентської
каденції то серед основних віг серед
основних досягнень буде не просто
створення Збройних Сил України українсь
армії а були
перенесені з 23 лютого на 14
жовтня свято дня захисника Вітчизни і
кожен знайде для себе своє пояснення
Чому так сталося для когось дуже важливо
що це свято співпадає з Днем Покрови
Святої
Богородиці хтось бачить в цьому
символізм тримання традицій української
армії Українського війська
з княжими
дружинами
з вояками УПА з вояками
УНР з славетними історичними
героями бо українська історія України Це
є історія українських героїв а для
когось дуже важливо герої 21 століття
які віддали своє життя для того щоби
зупинити російського агресора для того
щоб
врятувати
Україну в 14-му році 14
жовтня указом було запроваджено це свято
А два роки тому був відкритий цей
Музейний
комплекс і кожен
день українці приходять до цього
комплексу для того щоби вшанувати
пам'ять тих хто саме в цей
день дав своє життя для того щоб в
України було
майбутні Я хочу в цей день подякувати
всіх
захисників бо це не 23 лютого з
чоловічим святом в нас велика кількість
жінок-захисників України ми змінили
філософію цього Святу ми стали поважати
любити українське військо українську
армію незважаючи на те що відношення
діючої влади воно є дуже
прохолодним до захисників України вона
чужеє але я Хочу наголосити Що рівень
довіри рівень
авторитету Українського війська Збройних
Сил України є найвищим серед всіх щаблів
українських державних
інституцій і український народ заслужено
віддає
шалою поваги українцям
дорогі Захисники
України дорогі Чоловіки і
жінки Вітаю вас всім святом святом дня
захисника і Марино Дякую за
привітання Я також хочу сьогодні
привітати весь всіх
українців з зі святом захисника України
дійсно будь-яка держава не може існувати
без сильного
війська яке
береже суверенітет і цілісність
держави і ми сьогодні віддаємо нашу шану
і повагу всім
захисникам які боронили і боронять
сьогодні кордони України
І схиляємо голову перед тими Хто віддав
своє
життя
за вільну
незалежну і прогресивну Україну Слава
Україні і слава Українській армії Дуже
дякую дякую